(audience applauds)
- Wow.
- How are you?
- Yeah, great.
- Welcome to the show.
- Thank you, I'm so honored.
- Oh.
- I love you.
- Me too.
- I'm so happy to be here.
- Oh, thank you, we're stoked to have you.
I was so excited to have you.
So, people know you from "Teen Wolf".
- Yeah.
- Okay, but you're musical as well.
- I am, yeah.
- So, I learned that you started
even songwriting as a kid?
- I did, I had influences.
My favorite band was Blink 182,
when I was, like, seven years old.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- [Tyler] And so anything,
I just wanted to be...
(Tyler laughs)
Oh, look at that.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah.
- You little cutie.
- I was an actual full on fanatic
of Blink 182 and still am.
- Yeah, I think a lot of us were, yes.
And are, yes, it's a great band.
- Hmm-mm.
- And it was like, I feel
like for our generation,
I'm older than you, but our generation,
it was like, it was like, I don't know,
the first kind of punk
thing for me, like...
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so I loved it.
So, wait, so let's talk
about "Teen Wolf: The Movie"
So, does it pick up
wherever the series led of?
- No, it doesn't actually.
So, the series, it's 15
years after the series.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Which is wild, because my character
was always younger than Tyler.
- Yeah.
- I was always playing younger
and now my character is older than Tyler,
by like three years or two
years or something like that.
So, no, it's, it's a
completely different world.
My character has moved
away from Beacon Hills,
which is like, where
the town is in our show
and he's in Los Angeles trying to step
out of the hero ship role.
- Yeah.
- Which he was the hero and like,
the leader of of the pack back in the day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Now he's kind of trying to live life
as like a normal human, but
it doesn't work out so well.
- I do think that's really cool though,
when you take time in between,
because then, you have
more story to like uncover
from what's been happening in between,
I think that's really clever.
- It is cool, yeah.
One of our characters has
a son, a 15 year old boy.
- Yeah.
- Which is...
- That happens, all of
a sudden people grow up
and you're like, "I'm old".
(audience and Tyler laugh)
No, that's crazy.
That's cool that all the lives are like,
completely different.
- Yeah.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- I heard that you almost
played another wolf, right?
- I did, yeah.
I was, I was up against Taylor Lautner,
it was between he and I
for Jacob in "Twilight".
- [Kelly] That's huge.
- It, it, it would've been
huge, but I was really young,
I was like 16, I wasn't ready
for the type of attention that he got.
- Yeah.
- You know, so I had to wait a
couple more years and then...
- That's smart, because
it is a lot of attention.
- It was a lot.
He got a lot at that age
and I commend him for it,
but I don't know if I
was fully ready for it,
which I owe the me not
getting it, you know?
- Yeah, um, okay, so going back to music.
So, do you remember the
first song you ever wrote?
Because I, I remember mine.
- You do?
- Yeah, not that you need to know it,
I just mean, I think it stays with you.
- It does, for some reason
it does stay with me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Not a lot of things from like,
my 11 and 12 year old years
stay with me...
- Me neither.
- But that song for some reason.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's also a weird song,
it's a song that a 12 year
old shouldn't have written.
- Yeah.
- Partly, because like, I
grew up listening to Blink 182
and they always had some
fart joke or some adult joke.
(audience chuckles)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In there, and so, I wrote
a song about having a mojo,
which I got from, I think "Austin Powers".
- [Kelly] Mojo?
- Do you remember?
- I love, you're so young, but yes, yes.
(Tyler laughs)
That was, you were a kid
when that came out, sure.
- I was, I was, I was
pretty, I was pretty,
I was like 12 years old.
- Yeah.
- Maybe.
- [Kelly] I love "Austin Powers", yes.
- Yes.
- So, you wrote about your mojo?
- I wrote about my mojo.
- At 12 years old?
- [Tyler] At 12 years old, yeah.
- How was your mojo at 12 years old?
- I, I don't know.
(Tyler laughs)
- [Kelly] Did you have game?
- I don't know if I had
any game or any mojo.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But yeah, I wrote,
I wrote a little song.
- I love that, I just love
how it sticks with you.
Oh, I am, I think we, that's so weird.
We kind of, had your guitar
placed behind the couch.
- Oh, what?
- And I'm just thinking...
- How weird is that?
- Well, first of all, I want
to show you this guitar.
- Right.
- This is a badass guitar.
(audience gasps)
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- Cool, right?
- What?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Are these like,
oh wait, Bad Religion,
are these all like...
- These are punk bands.
- Yeah, I love this.
- Yeah, Authority Zero, Bad Religion,
there's a Blink on here somewhere.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Dead Kennedys, yeah, it's a punk rock.
- [Kelly] Different languages.
You've a palm tree for
happiness, I love all of this.
- Yeah, cool, right?
- [Kelly] I just wondered if you could,
because I know we remember
these, I remember my first song.
So what, how does yours go?
- So, last night I wrote the guitar to it,
because I didn't want to sing acapella,
I felt a little awkward.
- Oh, okay.
- I could have.
- Okay.
I think this is cooler, yeah.
- But I wrote, I wrote the
guitar to it last night.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- But the melody is the same
and the lyrics are the same.
I swear a couple of times in the lyrics,
so I'm changing those.
- Okay, or we could just
bleep you, but go for it.
- No, I don't, we don't
need, we don't need to bleep.
- You're keeping it classy,
San Diego, I like it.
(Tyler laughs)
Okay, yeah.
Go ahead.
You actually have the
stash for Ron Burgundy too.
- You're right.
- That's awesome.
- Stay classy, San Diego.
- Exactly. Okay, how does it go?
- [Tyler] So, I wrote this when I was 12.
- Okay.
(guitar strums)
♪ Here's the thing ♪
(audience and Kelly laughs)
It's a little punk, the
song is a little punk.
- Oh, no, hold up, wait, one second.
That, I love you, I love
that song, it's so punk.
- It's a little punk, yeah.
- [Tyler] No, no, it absolutely is.
- It's like pop rock, but yeah.
- I grew up listening to
the punk rock, pop punk
and that, like, I, it's one
of my favorite songs ever.
- Yeah.
- And I know how to play the entire thing.
- Oh.
- And it, because it is, it,
it reminds me of punk roots.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- [Tyler] It really does, yeah.
- Well, that made me feel cool, all right.
- It's awesome.
- Oh, thank you.
- You're a, you're a badass.
- It's one of my favorites
to sing just because
everybody loves singing
it, even grown ass men
in the audience.
(audience laughs)
Just, what.
- Hell, yeah.
- Yep, yep.
- I get it.
Okay, so here's "Mojo".
(guitar strums)
(Tyler hums)
♪ Me, me, me ♪
(Kelly laughs)
(guitar strums)
♪ Today I woke up a different person ♪
♪ It seems like I have no reason to live ♪
♪ Up with a hundred excuses ♪
♪ And I'm so, gosh darn useless ♪
♪ Once cool with a total mojo ♪
♪ No more, 1, 2, 3, go ♪
♪ Do, do, do, do, do ♪
And that's, that's, that's it.
(audience applauds)
- That's really catchy.
- It's catchy, right?
- Yeah.
- I was like, wait, I
was kind of expecting
to have to fake it and
be like, "That's cool".
That's cool, though.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's like really catchy.
- I mean, all my influences,
you including are...
- Okay, okay.
- Catchy badasses.
- That was really rad, I'm
probably gonna be singing that
later and hate you for it.
(Tyler laughs)
But, you know when you can't
get it outta your head.
- Right.
- That was really, mine wasn't that cool.
I'm not gonna talk about mine, okay.